let me ask you about this uh you worked
for 22 years
in like uh your your mainstream media i
guess 30 years mainstream media 30 years
right 27 years covering arizona as a
journalist and an anchor and 22 of those
years my last 22 for the fox affiliate
when did it go
wrong
in i think the media really you know
there were always places you could work
that were more liberal i mean obviously
cnn crazy um but you know you could also
say fox is more
reasonable if you're conservative and at
least they i i believe it was great a
great place to work but i think when
president trump came on the scene
candidate trump in 2015 when he came
down the escalator that's when i noticed
people in media and i'm talking all of
the networks starting to really lose it
even people that i thought were really
reasonable i'm like why are you so upset
about this guy he has a right to run
he meets the qualifications to run what
who cares if he runs
but it was a complete as as i like to
say he cro he cracked the
shells off the nuts do you think that it
was they didn't like trump or that they
wanted hillary to win so bad that they
didn't like whoever was coming and it
just turned out to be donald trump then
they turned him into a boogie man
i don't know i wonder if they had a deep
fear that oh my gosh this guy could win
and our and our lady won't win the one
one we want i don't know why i can't put
my finger on was there a feeling at fox
or anywhere that you were that there was
like a
an agenda to get a certain person
elected well let me put it this way when
you work in media 90
maybe 95
are
liberal for sure and a big chunk of them
are leftist socialists so
we know you know how we feel about our
candidates if if all of a sudden a
newsroom was 95
hardcore conservative it would change
the way things work but with so 95 being
liberal they're like oh gosh we don't
like this guy did you see around the
time when the uh so it was around 2016
you started to feel like things were
changing it was it just went really
crazy when trump came around and then i
really think it went to a whole new
level with covet and i i believe that
initially the 15 days to slow the spread
i think where we were all kind of like
whoa
what's going on here okay i'm willing to
slow things down for 15 days if we're
gonna i mean i was i was
reading the news and believing it we're
seeing fauci come out who's this new
scientist guy oh my gosh we gotta wipe
our groceries down
put our masks on i mean i i was
i believed it all be afraid of our
fellow neighbors and people to be afraid
and i work in a neighborhood and i i did
a prageru video and and i really kind of
lay out what happened in the media and
what brought me to walking away from a
very large comfortable paycheck
and um you know great benefits to just
walk away from that it has to be
something pretty bad did you notice
around this time that younger people
were coming into the workforce like were
you seeing more millennials join your
your office your newsroom yeah and and i
talked a little bit about that there was
a shift in and this also plays into how
media changed there was a shift in
losing some of the older more
established reporters and journalists
and i think it's because corporate media
took over and there's been a lot of
regional news
you know a company here and a company
there owned it and then it became now
five or six corporations own all the
media they bought up all these smaller
outlets maybe you had a family who owned
three stations they bought that up and
they just started accumulating more and
more media over the years and this
happened in the 80s and 90s and when
they accumulated more they wanted to
pare down the bottom line so let's say
tim you're a you know 50 year old
seasoned journalist who's been at the
station covering the you know the city
you live in for a long time and they go
tim
you know you're making a hundred and
twenty thousand and we're we're hiring
people right out of this college asu for
40 000
we can hire three people for the price
of you
and they start making your life
miserable and
you know saying no to every story you
want to cover and pretty soon tim goes i
don't want to work for this and guess
what those three millennials who've got
journalism degrees
are very yeah air quotes right there
theater degrees they're going social
justice they're warriors to be
communists yeah and i'll tell you my
thoughts on that and this is what this
is why i asked um you know based on what
i had seen when i was working for some
of these companies it was when they were
bringing in more and more young people
younger millennials is when they started
to have a bigger influence on the
culture
and what i discovered when i was uh you
know managing you know uh i was never a
manager but when i was
working with younger people you're a
manager now definitely now i mean i'm
the ceo of a company but uh not that
it's a big company but um what i found
is
many of these young people had never had
a job in their lives right they had
never worked and so what happens is they
go to school from kindergarten all the
way up until they're 22 or 24
they've always been told what to do and
by someone in charge
so they have no uh they not within them
they do not have the i'll figure this
out
attitude they're not entrepreneurs
they're not driven
quite literally i experienced when
working with these people is they'd come
up to you and say just tell me what to
do and i would say you need to figure it
out like here's your problem that's on
you i i i did not hire you so that i
could solve problems for you they were
given freedom as a child because of fear
that the media put in oh my gosh don't
let your kid ride their bike there could
be a bad guy who wants to nab him there
are bad guys out there don't get me
wrong but we when i was growing up we
had tons of freedom begin my my parents
would say get the heck out of the house
and don't come back in until we call you
and no matter we would go out and play
and
maybe that's the secret because i had
that too they didn't have any of that
freedom to grow up in and learn all
these little things and now cps is
showing up at people's homes because
they had their children walk home from
school that was literally a case that
happened here in the united states yeah
i think also i mean we talk about the
corporate media a lot but i think we
also have to acknowledge big tech social
media and the algorithms i think play
more of an imperative role to the
development of young children especially
with parents literally throwing their
phone at a baby just to keep them
occupied showing them their latest kind
of hollywood propaganda
uh you know that usually could probably
could have been produced by someone like
harvey weinstein or some other sicko or
creepo uh and and i think we have to
understand w when there's algorithms
they are literally shaping people's
perceptions of reality and when they do
that they could shape your reality to
whatever they want and i think they did
it they did it in such a twisted way
where we're seeing record high suicides
record high depressions record high
mental health issues and i think that's
done deliberately because when you have
someone who's not help happy when you
have someone who's not healthy they're
going to be someone that's going to be
dependent on someone who's going to be
that dependent the state the government
rather than of course the parents the
family members the individuals who are
standing up for each other as
responsible human beings we don't have
that anymore we have the state as the
mom and dad of people's lives and we saw
so many of people move into having the
state control their life during covet
they left the job had to close down they
left they're getting paid they're
sitting home and now the people who got
back out there and got to work
are being told
get the
job if i can say that or lose your job
with the mandates that are out right now
and so this is uh we're taking the final
group of people who are the working
engine in this society and they're
trying to get them to to walk away from
their job
and it's really frightening and then and
then what what do you do if they say get
the job or leave your your job and you
say no i'm not going to get that i don't
want it whatever the reason being you
you want your freedom you walk away now
you're on the system
they're they're destroying the working
class
are you familiar with the band the
offspring
no you've never heard of it so they're
actually can you sing can you sing a few
uh lines
separated you know that one from the 90s
maybe maybe you know uh i definitely
could and i'd like to and i actually uh
i don't
anyway anyway
uh they're a very big band they're very
big they were they were super huge in
the 90s they had monk yeah yeah they had
the biggest
the largest record sales or most amount
of records sold for any independent
label ever now i'm embarrassed that i
don't i probably will hear you should
you know the song pretty fly for a white
guy
uh what else i don't know
uh anyway
they had their drummer was actually
kicked out of the band because he had
guillain-barre syndrome
and
you can't get the vac well the doctor at
least said i you're not a candidate for
the united you can't get this because
if you get you if you have
guillain-barre syndrome they're worried
you can get nerve issues right and so
when uh i guess when when he talked to
the band or i don't know exactly what
happened all i know is ultimately he
ends up kicked out of the band for that
reason
became kind of a big issue in the news a
little bit for those that are interested
in music but that one to me was kind of
the most insane now i was on joe rogan's
show
and he was saying to me that well look
man that's tough because venues won't
let you perform with someone who's
unvaccinated and i was like i hear you i
hear you
so
this band the offspring is a business
they have an employee
they need to go to venues to sell their
product and many of these venues are
like if you're not vaccinated you can't
come in
it's insane to me that someone based uh
i mean
first of all it's insane to me there's a
mandate period
but to actually tell someone who's got a
medical condition you will lose your job
because of your medical condition i
thought that was illegal and you know
look it's a it's a clever workaround i
suppose if the venue won't let you in
the band can be like we're not letting
you go you just can't work for us
anymore but if it were me and this is
why i i have uh uh i don't know the
story from you know the the main guys at
the offspring dexter holland's the main
guy and then you know his guitarist
noodles i don't know what their side of
the story is but based on what i've
heard
if this dude said look my doctor says i
can't get it and they said get out
you're fired that's scumbaggery that is
that is that is that is wrong you know
what you do travis tritt is that is that
the country star who said you know i'm
not going to perform at these arenas
that are mandating um my fans come and
show any vaccine mandate or show any
vaccine passport or that my my staff my
band members
we're we're in tough times right now
we're in times where to make difficult
choices
and that might mean walking away from a
paycheck or walking away from a payday
for this band you know
when if we don't start standing up and
doing the right thing what's the next
step comedian jim brewer also did that
as well yeah jim brewer also did that i
just want i just want to point out again
distress
i don't know exactly what went on with
this band and i want to be careful
because for all i know like they were
throwing pies at each other and people
get fired people get fired sometimes but
if uh operate under the assumption that
there is a band worth millions of
dollars if you google search the network
of net worth of dexter holland it's 80
million dollars that doesn't mean it
really is but the dude is particularly
wealthy
you've got a drummer i think who played
with him for over a decade i think like
14 years
and all of a sudden this thing happens
where it's like venues aren't going to
let you in
it is mind-blowing to me and this is
this is where i say like economically
i'm probably lefty i would never i would
never do that to somebody if if i had a
company that was worth 80 million
dollars and we had we had cash and and
the government came down i would do two
things the first i'd say then we will
only play venues
that don't have this
and if for some reason we have no choice
because there's a city with fans and we
have to play
i will find a session drummer for this
show buddy you've been with us for over
a decade i will not let you down i could
i can't a fathom a reality in which
there are people who are like i may be
worth 80 million dollars but screw you
you're fired because of because of what
they're doing with this mandate that to
me is sickening well and that's a good a
solution okay if we have to perform
we've got fans who want to see us we
have our band you know we bring somebody
in you pay the guy who's part of the
band for how many years
and then
you don't fire him
people are going to be sued later
because we're going to find out this is
all unconstitutional yeah and i think
that's why and this band has to
someday and i know i don't know if
you're religious
meet their maker
and you're going to meet your maker and
you're going to say i did the right
thing i did the wrong thing
or you're going to look at your kids one
day and say when this country hopefully
we're saved you're going to say i was
part of saving this country this is
supposed to be a punk band
it is exactly this is sounds like a
personality issue
it's just too too weird to not be i
don't know man after uh 14 15 years yeah
so i don't believe that but don't these
bands make all their money by performing
live now i heard that you know with the
record labels you're not making what you
think you these guys would make so they
have to perform live some of the people
from the 90s got fathered and
grandfathered in and they're still
raking it in but wouldn't being a punk
band wouldn't it be so much cooler to
say you know what we we're going to go
to this arena and no screw it we're not
going there right we're going to
somebody find a big field what did tim's
house out here with all this land and
we're going to do our freedom stand
right we've got 50 acres we're going to
free thomas that's what we're doing you
know and that's why we luke came up with
the name this is that freedom stand are
you holding concerts there we are going
to that's great well hopefully it's west
virginia so nobody really cares do
anything you want you almost can't well
when we drove out here i was like is
this a blair witch project yeah what's
going on here we are a few miles like
that
were a few miles away from where they
filmed blair which apparently that's
what i was told yeah you know i can't
believe how thick the forest is out here
that's great i mean you can't even walk
through it probably without hitting a
tree we had a bear attack we had we had
a bear so we have a chicken coop it's
very nice
bigger than my house no that's that's
new chicken city okay the ruins of old
chicken city are in front the rubble and
yeah it's the old but we had a bear i
guess look with the lockdowns there's
less refuse animals become more
desperate and a bear actually this this
is basically our front porch so you have
a front porch and then to the left is
where the coop is and a bear came and
actually tried ripping it open and we we
had you know people around us being like
there was a bear through the
neighborhood and we saw the metal ripped
off and we were like that was the bear
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you